the doors didn't open for three months
it just hovered there nobody could get
in and they eventually decided after
much deliberation that the best thing to
do would be to physically cut their way
in so I very purposefully wanted all of
district 9 to feel as real as possible
even though you know 50% of the film is
presented in a cinematic way the
environment is is a hundred and ten
percent real it's pure pure Johannesburg
Johannesburg City but how are you going
to present the visual effects that are
computer-generated to feel as though the
camera recorded them on on the day you
build your computer-generated aliens and
you put them into your real live action
background you treat the effects no
differently to anything else I think
that when you start treating them as
though their visual effects and you put
them on a gold and kind of pedestal then
they become important and the way that
you think about them because they cost a
lot of money starts it starts to make
them feel synthetic you have to kind of
just disregard them you know you have to
treat them like every other sort of
thing and then and then they begin to
feel quite real or some human history
has changed it's like I wanted to look
as grotty and kind of real as possible a
little bit of how we went about doing is
a combination of the camerawork and the
lighting conditions and you know even to
a certain extent sometimes the exposure
on the cameras makes it feel a little
bit more real because you're not putting
the visual effects up on a pedestal you
just they just happen to be there and
you just happen to be filming like three
units apart we basically distilled
called props or costumes prosthetics
weapons robots
kind of stuff in the end that went out
instead of pluses dressed up and dirtied
up and made to look even more disgusting
than when I left at work so the aliens
actually went through a huge design
process and they all came down to one
design and we actually went here she
went away and did some test footage with
that came back designed a completely new
alien that looked nothing like the first
one the final version that's you know
it's just a tank let's do this wanted to
make something more imposing more
threatening or dangerous district 9
residents are violent and unpredictable
so the district 9 weapons are are
actually a hodgepodge of different
things some of them are supposed to be
weapons but actually many of them were
designed to look like tools and that's
offensive at the film that kind of
changed as we went through some of the
concepts that we started with that you
know inform the designs actually changed
throughout the film some of them were
actually mining tools and weapons and
something designs that were supposed to
be implements and not for them that they
will new they'll ultimately going to be
used as a weapon anyway it's like the
same way someone would use a chainsaw
and then others were literally like
military start with it although I wanted
those to like a you know obviously the
technology is so evolved that there's no
reason camouflaging and or making them
look you know discreet so they have
bright colors you know white record
orange beans going through them and part
of that was morning to harken back
actually to 80s illustrative
science-fiction in a way I'm not trying
to reinvent the wheel and I was doing
those designs an innocent ship for
instance it's a saucer you know you
could have made the thing you need any
different shape in fact a bunch of the
designers did come up with really
abstract shapes you know that weren't
saucer like at all about alternate
lenient
because it's just iconic right it just
you know instantly what it is it
represents something and it has an
immediate connection the whole Verret a
sort of veneer that the film has creates
this illusion of when you put science
fiction into that it creates the
solution of kind of the strange reality
because we've seen glossy Hollywood
films with science fiction and then
we've seen hand-held documentaries about
you know X wires ad topic and if you
merge those you get kind of in my
opinion you get kind of a cool very real
feeling science fiction piece